[Music]
and I know it says the case for
classical liberalism but my day job is
actually promoting classical liberalism
and I'm going to tell you what I think
it is why it is extremely frustrating
and annoying in the present political
environment in the United Kingdom to
promote it why I think that I'm right
and virtually everybody else is wrong
and why I'm disappointed that I haven't
persuaded as many people of my case as I
think I should and how I'm gonna change
how I try and persuade thee
so first thing I want to talk about I'm
gonna speak for about 25 minutes or so
and then you can ask me all sorts of
difficult questions first thing to say
is what do I mean by classical
liberalism pretty vague term and what I
mean by it is an acceptance that the
state shouldn't do very much it should
enforce the rule of law it should make
sure that the courts operate properly it
should otherwise basically try and get
out of people's lives and allow
individual men and women to make their
own choices now there's not a scientific
justification law of classical
liberalism there isn't a number you can
attach to it classical liberals disagree
about how much money should the
government spend should it be ten
percent of national income 20 percent 30
percent of national income how much
redistribution should the state
undertake but the classical ISM
classical liberalism is basically
associated with getting the government
out of people's business
lower regulation being good lower taxes
being good and the state having a fairly
limited role it is essentially
free-market capitalism in all but name
although a slightly wider view classical
liberals are also extremely interested
in freedom of speech issues of personal
liberty not just economic liberty it's
the economic Liberty side that I want to
talk to you about today
and ladies and gentleman I'm losing
pretty badly
according to a recent opinion poll 61%
of 18 to 24 year olds in the United
Kingdom held a favorable view towards
socialism and in 2016 more people had a
favorable view of socialism and
capitalism most claim they would rather
live in a socialist country the terms
and frames of debate are changing pretty
radically here two weeks ago CNBC ran a
headline capitalism is in crisis and
last week the Financial Times which
perhaps for some considerable period of
time has been considered to be the
newspaper outlet that would be the most
free-market and capitalist actually ran
its entire episode its entire issue on
capitalism time for a reset we see
anti-capitalist protests everywhere
hitting the streets nearly all the time
on occasion I have considered organizing
a pro capitalist protest but I don't
like being alone and I'm not quite sure
who else would turn up but I'm under no
illusions whatsoever that the public
mood is highly skeptical about
free-market liberalism and activists and
the media and politics in general is
moving against it Michael Moore the
famous documentary filmmaker in America
has actually said capitalist capitalism
is an evil and you cannot regulate evil
this is not an understated sort of
critique this is a pretty ballsy
critique of capitalism I actually find
on the side of the argument in British
politics when I listening to or
discussing things with politicians who
you would expect to be advocates of
free-market capitalism
I guess members of parliament in the
Conservative Party tend to be more
sympathetic to free-market capitalist
idea
Byron margin politicians in other
parties but they do tend to be
apologists so once you have the Michael
Morel saying capitalism is an evil and
you cannot regulate evil oftentimes I'll
be listening to a member of parliament
who you might well consider to be an
apologist or a defender of free-market
capitalism and they will always begin
their speech with I am a free-market
sort of person but and will then give me
a large list of ways in which they think
actually the state should be rather more
and free markets should do rather less
and all sorts of areas in which they
think the free market is failing so I am
under no illusions at all the backdrop
and the world I live in in Britain but I
think across the Western world as a
whole is one that has lost its faith in
free markets and small states it's one
that believes that the system is somehow
rigged and that we need it probably a
greater dose of intervention by politics
the state or other agencies and a
probably a larger state to go with it so
I know I'm on the backfoot now let me
tell you what that's what depresses me
but let me tell you what irritates me
and what irritates me is that I
genuinely believe that the empirical
evidence for capitalism and a free
market economy and a relatively small
role for the state is absolutely
overwhelming if you want human
prosperity and the relief of suffering
and economic growth and assisting the
poor to be your key a I think the
empirical evidence are in my view the
jury is in and I want to just share some
of that evidence with you and I'll be
happy to talk to you about it but too
often I think we we deal with anecdotes
or a feeling and I'm trying to make this
a science and I'm just very worried that
very few people seem to believe in the
science so I had a look at the report
that comes out I think
called the Fraser Institute and it
releases a report each year called the
economic freedom of the World Report
ranking the level of freedom of a
hundred and sixty two economies now I've
said it's a science it's probably not a
perfect science how do you measure
freedom you know you can measure the
amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere but freedom is a slightly
trickier thing to measure
but what they mean by their freedom it
indexes the following things what's the
overall size of the government how much
does it spend how much does it intervene
in lives lower would be free a higher
would be less free what's the state of
the legal system and property rights can
you get two recourse through the courts
of law or are they wholly corrupt if you
do the deeds to a property be that a
house or something else is it respected
under the legal system sound money is
the is the country operating in a way
that it isn't piling up debts or
printing money or photo copiers in the
basement
what's the freedom to trade
internationally is it easy to sell your
goods abroad or your services abroad or
to bring them in and what's the amount
of regulation and the less is better
from the point of view of measuring
freedom according to this index a
relatively low spending government
relatively light regulation a good court
system but one that focuses on property
rights and the government that doesn't
spend beyond its means so you can argue
a bit about their methodology but that's
what they're trying to measure and if
you take their lists and you look
through all 162 nations and you look at
the freest quartile the top 25% of
countries typically towards the low tax
low regulation defend property rights
make sure you're operating sound money
sort of end well that freest quartile
has on average and income six times
higher than the least free quartile if
you're in that top 25% of nations which
indeed the United Kingdom is
the average individual income across
them is a little shy of 37 thousand US
dollars per annum and your ofin you're
in the bottom quartile the worst 25%
then the average income there is about
$6,000 per annum quite a difference and
even if you're worried about inequality
in your own country the bottom 10
percent of income earners in those top
quarter of countries make seven times
more than the bottom 10 percent of
earners in those lows in those lowest
least free countries so if you're in the
bottom end of a free country the bottom
10 percent your average earnings are a
little over ten thousand US dollars a
year but if you're in the bottom of the
bottom percent it's not even obviously
in your interest your average earnings
are about fifteen hundred dollars a year
so in terms of picking a place to be
poor your best to pick a free country to
be poor in you would be far far far
better off simply about a third of all
people in the least free economies live
in extreme poverty absolute poverty are
literally struggling to get by on on $2
a day extreme poverty in the top 25% of
countries is almost too limited
eliminated in terms of absolute terms
are there people who actually cannot eat
and put a roof over their heads for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the institute of arts and ideas
at iai TV
you